how long do you think is reasonable for  people to have access to an abortion  the limits i feel need to be set between  the doctors  and the patients and not between you and  me  or you know the current or previous  president of the united states  or you know the church when you look at  the studies on why people access  abortion after 20 weeks  the top four reasons are it's a very  young girl  it's a woman who thought it was the  menopause it's somebody who's inner  escaping an abusive relationship  or it's a wanted pregnancy that becomes  unwanted  in my experience the reasons wanted  pregnancies have become unwanted  have included something goes  catastrophically wrong with the  pregnancy  um we had a situation where the woman's  husband killed himself  she didn't feel she could afford another  child a couple their four-year-old  developed leukemia  and they were like we think we need to  focus on our four-year-old right now